[Music]
jake is in atlanta georgia hi jake
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how's it going great what's up
so i'm 22. just graduated college in may
i'm a pretty good job project engineer
um
pretty much as soon as i graduated
college i needed a new car
um went out got a brand new car my dad's
in the car business we kind of talked
about it given everything that's going
on by me a newer used car um didn't make
a ton of sense
um
i drive a long ways to work i'm still
living with my parents um i intend to
live with them for probably about a year
um if not possible i kind of never want
to have to get an apartment um
but you know with living at home with my
parents i drive a long ways to work and
driving into atlanta every day
what's a long ways
um it takes me about an hour
i'm putting probably 70 miles a round
trip every day on my car
yeah and what did you buy
uh toyota tacoma
okay so what 30 grand
uh it was 40 but my loan is about 26.
okay
and and um i have no student debt um so
that was kind of how is it you want us
to help you
well my question was with you know i've
already put i had the truck for about a
little less than three months i already
have seven thousand miles on it
um
you know putting those kind of miles on
a truck um you know my main concern is
that you know given the length of the
loan that i have
that you know i'm gonna get caught in a
cycle where
um you know i'm putting
i'm gonna need to buy a new truck before
i pay off the loan that sort of thing um
so i talked to my dad and we talked
about potentially um doing something
where i trade my truck in every year and
she shoot a new one
but then
you know at that point i'm in a cycle
where i'm always having a car payment i
never have a car paid off and i'm always
losing a little bit of money
and your question is
well my question is mainly um you know
what do you recommend for somebody who's
in their you know early twenties just
out of college um you know do you think
it's a absolutely terrible idea to keep
my check or should i you know go into
something that's not quite as reliable
but you know i don't have that better
off you know putting my money somewhere
else
i i
perceive from the way you're asking this
question and some of the statements that
you've made that you don't listen to the
show very often or much
i do listen uh occasionally um i
definitely know your standpoint on uh
buying a new car
okay
and and debt jake and that
you know his stance on debt
our stance everybody's okay
okay how much money do you make out of
curiosity
60 000.
we couldn't hear you you're breaking up
60.
did you say 60 000.
i did okay
all right let me give you a formula
that will 100 percent ensure
you're a broke butt 35 year old
okay
follow the plan that you are on
buy new cars and keep buying them and
trading them in and running up miles on
them and you will be a broke butt 30
year old that has supported your
father's company beautifully and you
will be broke
some of the most broke 35 year olds i
meet have continually traded for new
cars
over and over and over and over again in
the first decade of their working life
and they started out with this idiotic
idea that because they graduated from
college they deserve to be 30 000 in
debt on a freaking truck
so no i i'm afraid your dad's not going
to like dave ramsey
because i don't like his advice for his
son at all
i would tell you to sell the truck get
you a cheaper truck move out of your
parents house into a rental close to
work
and save your money
and quit investing in things that go
down in value like a rock and then
scratch your head and wonder why you're
broke that's where chevy got that like a
rock